es la primera visita oficial del
presidente de Estados Unidos
y Aliado Canadá donde el Primer Ministro
Justin trudó lo recibió con los brazos
abiertos es un verdadero placer dar la
bienvenida al presidente biden a Ottawa
de vuelta a otawa me alegro mucho de
verte yo el principal objetivo de la
visita reforzar su cooperación económica
y social durante la reunión anunciaron
un acuerdo sobre la migración ilegal en
la frontera compartida un tema sensible
para ambos bandos según este Canadá
podrá devolver a los migrantes en
caliente sin permitirles la entrada al
país a cambio de conceder 15.000
solicitudes de asilo un movimiento
criticado por las organizaciones
humanitarias Estados Unidos y Canadá
trabajarán juntos para desalentar los
cruces ilegales en las fronteras y
aplicar el acuerdo del Tercer país
plenamente y totalmente actualizado
también discutieron otros temas como un
plan conjunto de defensa para poder
plantar cara a otras potencias como
Rusia o china
lo que hace que este sea un momento tan
trascendental es que nuestro mundo
nuestro modo de vida se enfrenta a
múltiples amenazas al mismo tiempo
e hicieron hincapié en su apoyo a
Ucrania en la región aseguraron que
siguen preocupados por la situación de
seguridad en Haití Canadá suele ser la
primera visita al extranjero del
presidente estadounidense Y aunque con
biden no fue así han querido subrayar
que la unidad norteamericana sigue
intacta